Hello, John. It's Tuesday, January 9th. I'm
in Detroit, Michigan. It's very windy and
cold. I'm standing in the only place in the
continental United States where you can look
south and see Canada, which you are doing
right now. I'm also standing in front of General
Motors headquarters. It's a very, very big
building.
It's really nice of you to say that I live
in a way that is commensurate with my values.
I haven't been feeling that way lately. For
the new year I drove to Spokane and I flew
to Reno and then I drove to Lake Tahoe. And
then I did that all in reverse for, like,
a three day long party. And now, like a week
later, I've excepted an invitation from General
Motors to visit the North American International
Auto Show in Detroit, Michigan.
I was invited to this because I write for
a few environmental blogs and there are some
environmental things going on here. Those
are my values. This is not my values.
It's kind of difficult to convey what's really
going on here. It's a pretty gigantic spectacle.
I looked earlier, there's fake lichen on those
fake rocks. And up here, fake fire. I don't
even know how they're doing that; it's amazing.
And here we have the weirdest, prettiest fake
waterfall ever and it spells things.
Right here, we have a Jeep that has got stuck
to a wall, and all the people in that Jeep
have had to jump out of the Jeep because they
were stuck to a wall.
General Motors is giving away hot dogs to
a long line of people.
So lame. Oh my god.
[Girls]: Hi John! Hey John! See what you're
missing?
[Hank]: Ehhehehehehehehehehe, yeah.
As for the Brotherhood 2.0 book club, I'm
really excited that you're giving me opportunities
to read so many books about genocide. I love
genocide. In terms of what you're going to
read, apparently none of our viewers want
you to read anything because they all want
you to write. So you should just go ahead
and read whatever it is you're writing. I'm
gonna make that your one option. You have
to read the book you are writing.
And as for what to call it, you're gonna have
to give me some time. Also, it'd be nice to
know what it was about. I'd also like to say
happy birthday to Jessalyn Shields, a Brotherhood
2.0 viewer and one of my best friends.